i want to take a look at some tweets
that were very controversial from you um
you took a lot of heat from people on
the right as well i know you had an
exchange with glenn beck
that people should go check out that was
really really interesting and compelling
let's take a look at this one i'm going
to group these as a three i want to do
all three tyler i'll read them first one
is warrants should be being issued as we
speak to have democrat homes raided in
districts with red judges and red
sheriffs communists are religious
zealots all religious zealots understand
is fear and pain this will not stop
until they're afraid then you say
you have this is not back-to-back but
nonetheless well maybe it was
back-to-back oh no it was a little bit a
little bit removed you have no idea the
kind of authoritarian i'd support if it
means stopping the communists this is
not an insult i want a monster now that
one went viral a lot of people took
issue with it and this recent one i
believe this was yesterday uh or or
pretty close to it in response to the
new york ag ordering steve bannon to be
walked in front of the media you said
this doesn't stop until red areas and
red da's start arresting democrats on
television there is no appeal to norms
or principles that will make this stop
make them afraid of it happening to them
or this gets much worse from here today
it's bannon tomorrow it's you so talk a
little bit about what you mean
when you say that you would support an
authoritarian because to a lot of people
on the right that became a no right that
was we immediately said well no we can't
become them we can't we won't be able to
criticize them if we become them we
won't be able to remove evil if we
become evil so talk a little bit about
where you're coming from on that
well first of all uh i'm not interested
in criticizing the communist i'm
interested in defeating the communists
that's one two
uh i don't want an authoritarian
jedediah that's that's not what i want
at all i i want a small tiny government
and i want to live in the land of the
free that's that's what i want but god
didn't give me a choice did you get a
vote did he come down and ask you what
period of time you live in if my only
two options are
have some kind of franco-like
authoritarian which i don't want but
have so franco like a tour authoritarian
rise on the right to run these
communists out of my society or my
option b is i live in a nation where
doctors will publicly advertise their
services to remove the penis of teenage
boys and breasts of teenage girls and
then hold up the newly mutilated child
on social media social media not only
brag about it but make a fortune doing
it if that's the society we're going to
descend into and my choice is that or
franco bring on el caldeo because that's
no choice at all for me i will not live
in a society where we murder babies by
the million i will not live in a society
where we sexually abuse children where
we groom them where we treat old people
like crap where we have become this
perverted degenerate filth out there i
will not live in that kind of country
and i'm not alone in that i don't want
an authoritarian i want all this evil to
stop but
this evil because it is evil it's not
wrong or bad or liberal or left that's
evil that's demonic because it's evil
you're never going to criticize it or
call it a hypocrite or or do any of the
things that conservatism has been and
make it stop they're not worried about
being hypocrites they're not worried
about being criticized they're worried
about victory they're worried about
their evil defeating your good their
darkness defeating your light
the only thing that will make religious
zealots stop and all these lgbtq stuff
blm climate change that they're all just
cultural marxists now they're all
communists they just change the branding
of it all the only thing that has ever
made these people stop is fear and pain
you think you get mad when donald trump
gets its home raider they can't do this
can you imagine if a republican
that's that's what we get from the right
maybe one democrat congressman that had
his door kicked in by a swat team after
that happened not one see you know
they're not worried about hypocrisy
they're worried about victory and
they're busy making it happen yeah and
my problem with that and i understand
where you're coming from with that my
problem is i don't want to live in a
society where fear and pain get
normalized from the top first of all i
never would trust an authoritarian
authoritarians go rogue and one day you
think they're doing one thing and the
next day they're doing something
different because an authoritarian is by
nature
evil it just is anyone who wants to
suppress or oppress is by nature evil
but here's my solution one of them and
we have many problems in this country
one problem i think that can be fixed is
what's happening in the blue cities and
my advice to everyone
everyone said oh you know what you're
from new york city
you should stay there and you should
vote these people out and my response
was you're never going to vote these
people out because fidel castro wins on
the democrat ticket in new york it just
doesn't matter there's not enough people
with sane minds to get rid of this so i
told everybody get out of the cities get
out of them get out of the blue cities
pick up your family your money your
business
get up go to a red city go to a red
state invest there make your voices
heard and let those cities sink so
deeply that ultimately in order to pick
themselves up they have to change there
is no other option it did happen to new
york city once because giuliani came in
after years and years and years of
disgusting filth in new york city i mean
it was horrible it was crime infested
and it got so bad that then giuliani won
an election and everything got shaped up
and it looked pretty good for a while so
it can happen even in a place like new
york city that's my number one
then you also have to address though the
hands that are being held between big
pharma between you know we talked about
fda and cdc all year it's all corrupt
and all of that holds hands with big
government i'm not convinced that any
authoritarian is going to be able to fix
that so my message on this is that
it's just too scary and i understand
your
i understand what you're saying that
it's not a time to criticize it's a time
to stand up against it's just too scary
to promote authoritarianism of any kind
one and two that's not what we're about
right we are not we want ultimately a
free society so if you advocate for
authoritarianism if you say there's no
other choice right i don't want
authoritarianism but that's what we're
left with and that has to rise up
against authoritarianism you lose you
lose anyway because you don't have a
free society at the end of the day right
we all lose so we have to win in the
battle of the ideas we have to
ideas and
we have to get people we have to to
inspire people to get out of these
cities and they will sink they will sink
jesse
okay one i 100 support you in moving
that is that is big time true people
need to balkanize get to a red area and
become an activist when you get to a red
area fortify it because they promise you
they will come for that area too that's
one two i guess it also depends on what
we're discussing when it comes to
authoritarian because freedom is
something that americans fundamentally
do not understand they think they do and
it's odd because they live in the land
of the free but they think they
understand it the footlight of the free
land of the free all the time ask
somebody on the right ask somebody a
pundit or a tv radio guy on the right
ask him ask him how they got their
freedom inevitably you know what they'll
say the constitution that's the
constitution
the constitution is nothing the
constitution is a piece of paper you
have your freedom because the people who
wanted to take it from you brave men
went and shot them in the face
they went and killed all the guys who
wanted to take your freedom and then
they wrote the constitution and after a
whole lot of blood they handed you a
free country freedom is not something
you acquire by practicing it if you want
these people to stop assaulting you stop
using the fbi cdc so on and so forth if
you want them to stop coming for school
board parents if you want them to stop
doing the frightening things you're
doing you're going to have to do
something to dissuade them because i
promise they're not going to wake up
tomorrow morning in the fbi and say guys
oh we do look bad don't we dang you know
what let's change our ways i feel bad i
feel terrible that day is never going to
come unless they get stung unless there
is something they fear
there is no stopping them we're not
dealing with bad we're dealing with evil
and there is no bottom i see like we
were talking about the the trans stuff a
little bit earlier i see so many people
talk about how we're going to reach some
bottom how there's going to be some
bottom and that will come out of this
whole thing there's no bottom
with demons there is no bottom it's
trans stuff today that'll be that'll be
that'll be a distant memory ten years
from now when they're openly promoting
pedophilia they already have a term for
it minor attracted persons and that that
won't be the end either you'll see
you'll see pedophilia openly depicted in
film it'll go down from there because
it's a bottomless pit that doesn't stop
until it's stopped by the forces of good
whatever those forces are i want them to
be freedom-like loving forces shadow die
i don't want some franco-type but if
those are my only two choices i know
what i'm picking yeah i mean and i think
what you're talking about is like a
creeping normality of decay that's
happening right it becomes you know it's
shocking at first and then all of a
sudden it becomes the new normal and i
actually had covered on the show videos
of people who were
justifying pedophilia and saying oh you
know we shouldn't we shouldn't be mean
to them we shouldn't label them
pedophiles that's a degrading term i
mean so it is it is already there right
we are already at that point um
and i i think ultimately
a lot of this is going to come down to
families
parents people who are looking at the
next generation i have a two and a half
year old everything that i do i do for
him it's going to come down to people
who are saying what's this going to look
like in 30 years and who have little
people around them that are going to be
growing up in that world and they
absolutely will not tolerate what's
going on and i think this is going to
come from
there's a lot of people that are
disgusted deeply disgusted by what's
going on in schools there's these
puberty blockers that you know they're
advocating giving to children now
they're coming for the kids jesse we
know it they're coming for the kids on
the the vaccine stuff with the the
mandates with the masks they they are
coming for the children if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]